اذا قالت كتائب القسام ان عددا من جنود
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قتلوا بعد سحق
الطيران الاسرائيلي الياته لعدم قدره قوات
الانقاذ على سحبها مشيره الى ان استهداف
الاليات الصهيونيه في الحرب اسفر عن مقتل
واصابه عدد كبير من ضباط وجنود العدو
ومرتزقته وكشفت كتائب القسام في احصائيه
تنشرها لاول مره على قناتها في تيليجرام
ان مقاتليها دمروا بقذائف الياسين 105
اكثر من
1108 اليات اسرائيليه منذ بدايه الحرب
مضيفه بان الاليات الصهيونيه المدمره شملت
962 دبابه و55 ناقله جند
و74 جرافه وثلاث حفارات اضافه الى 14
مركبه
عسكريه وقالت كتائب القسام ان عنا صيرها
اشتبكوا مع قوه اسرائيليه في مفترق
الصناعه بغزه واوقع افرادها بين قتيل
وجريح اضافت الكتائب في بيان ان قواتها
استهدفت دبابه من نوع ميركافا اربعه
بقذيفه الياسين 105 في محيط مفترق الصناعه
بمدينه غزه